I welcome to this video but late start I
had somehow screwed up the recording
window but it turns out that my opponent
the darshan mustn't age from the US took
some time as well took some seconds okay
we got a scotch opening with Bishop b5
just curious never see that one yeah
we'll just just develop don't really
think that Bishop b5 can be too great I
mean not sure what the justification is
20 sec the pond k maybe go here to avoid
the directv file yeah okay can play
night b3 and stuff get it back but it's
not a particularly great setup than
bishop will be fibers just a bit
strangely placed ok gaining a tempo to
interesting could have take care o can
also check with the pawn now ok but this
is just simple I'd good yeah this is a
completely open position where black has
the two bishops wow really ok i have
three just weekends this diagonal
immensely I mean oke for was hanging I
still thought he must play um yeah play
I'm peace move to protected I know after
c3 blackest enjoying a very nice game
but let's see him how do i do a
can I already get something substantial
what about c5 whereas this night going
to see two to be three something like
that he doesn't have many many moves
here anyway Bishop f5 c5c fibers are not
leading to much I think okay now this is
this is a simple muth just developing
like it's probably better in various
ways so this is just one of them you can
now take I cannot take do you want to
sing and threatening c5 yeah okay they
already thought I would threaten c5 him
takes I can take here maybe yeah ok so
what it's not really really nice the
problem is if he goes to somewhere else
I could rookie to now Murray active
position and of course c4 I need to play
c4 at some point to get this back into
play
yeah well I could have played rock d 2
maybe I should have done that hmm I
would have played could have played
rookie one now yeah let's say it's good
anyway that much is clear but
determining the the maximum is not so
easy as usual maybe look-see to keep
keep the pieces on whoopsie to not sure
check back come on I'm spending too much
time it's terrible at the moment I'm
never never really quick but at the
moment germ tend to spend an awful
amount of time in positions where the
opponents are just playing really really
bad but I make it difficult for myself
because I look I look at the positions
for ages and then play move that I could
have played after five seconds just a
really bad practical approach I mean
around here those moves are simple and
they they keep my edge maybe not the
best but it's it's really good and
intent and a decent I mean why not just
play it quicker if he exchanges now I'm
going to win with Bishop see one he has
got all of the pawns on dark squares
that's not exchanging is also not easy
how do you not exchange him no case
attacking on but I have I have to check
here King age too
shouldn't this win somehow queen bee one
check king age to the show check came
back how to believe that
do check and see it at the moment check
I can go to h1 how do I win now I don't
see how of course I can draw but the
draw is not what I want
I can go to no I cannot you don't see
you in him check don't see you in quincy
one Queen h1 it's not winning it is got
Quincy and check time warner check check
yeah I must I must make the draw him
game Tehran I have no time I didn't
don't see the win that probably exists
yeah I saw it Bishop b6 takes with stock
versus only on minus 0.6 on 0.8 of
course black black is totally winning
here Quincy one win sir yeah it's really
not great at the moment yeah and very
easily of course but what is this move
we must exchange now I can play that one
but it doesn't really make much of a
difference this end game I'm going to
win even with even with even less time
just just very easily winning yeah and
then there really must be a win with
with this kind of position around here
it's already a bit strange that it's not
exploding immediately c5 is a better
counting to the comp but this is the
always keeps an advantage at least this
is reassuring yeah blankets is
constantly better of course check yeah
it's not so it's not the best but it
keeps her keep something yeah but at the
end i didn't i didn't have the time to
check to to win it really this is check
what the comp wants to do to continue
but thought Quincy age should
this okay I control that check okay now
and then c4 or something yeah of course
this I can just continue but I was down
to 20 seconds it was difficult to do
play on and that's not as
straightforward when I mean it's
certainly clearly better for me but
still needs to be played out alright
thanks for watching